- How did you think we
did with the Snoop song?
- I've got my notes ready.
- Okay.
I'm Okay with you lying.
That's, I'm okay with that.
- I wanna know.
No, this is my go to karaoke song,
so I wanna know.
- I didn't come here to lie, nahm sayin'?
(all laugh)
- You should be a coach on The Voice.
- I came here to tell the truth.
You all wanna hear the truth?
[Crowd] Yeah.
- Okay, well, wow.
- Wait, he really has notes written down.
- What?
- He has notes.
- [Kal] Wow all right.
- [Kelly] He has notes.
- [Kal] Yes.
- I'm ready.
I'm ready.
- Hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo.
(crowd cheers)
- (laughs)
What's your notes?
- Well, Kelly, you give me a
lot of confident projection.
- Okay.
Mm-hmm.
- [Guest] Because, you're on
live instruments.
'Cause this is live drums.
And you have to have a
different level of confidence
to be on top of those and be
in the pocket, nahm sayin'?
- Okay.
- In the go-go world, we really, you know,
we really have you on pockets.
You was really in your pocket.
I was, was--
- Oh, usually
I'm not on my, in my pocket.
- Oh, so you get shifted a
lot when you record music?
- Yeah, usually I'm like
way, I'm like Willie Nelson.
I'm like way behind the beat usually.
- Who's Willie Nelson?
- What?!
- Joking!
Joking!
- Oh!
I was like.
- I smoked wit 'em outside.
- I love it!
(claps)
- You had a little run at the end,
where I was like, "Oh,
you can't help yourself."
- I can't help myself, but see, yeah.
(sings) lay back, I know I had to, I know.
- She couldn't help it, she ran it.
Jenna dudes don't sound like that sugar.
(Kelly and crowd laughs)
You sang it, you can't help it.
- I had to make it me.
- But that's what talent does.
- Okay, okay, thank you.
(whoops)
- All right, what about Kal?
- Okay yeah, we're gonna get there.
(Kal and Kelly laugh)
- I said, Kal been waitin'
for this Snoop moment
for a long time and it shows
because he was on point, he was ready,
he was focused.
- Yeah.
- And you nailed it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And the last thing is, can I sign y'all
because the demographic would be insane.
(laughing and cheering)
- Yes! Yes!
- My first signing on
whatever the hell I'm calling
this records is these
guys, we're gonna come up
with a new name later.
- Special K!
We're both K, special K!
(laughing and cheering)
- Special K.
- Yes.
- Yo, yo, yo.